E
WAS NO EVIDENCE OF ELECTION
FRAUD OR GLITCH OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT AT ALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH THE PANEL.
GLORIA, THESE TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN MEADOWS, WE SEE CONGRESS
MAN PERRY THERE HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT TO
OVERTURN DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU HAVE MORE THAN 400 TEXTS
WITH MEADOWS FROM MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
PERRY WAS SITING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND, YOU KNOW,
INCLUDING WITH GREAT BRITAIN,
ITALIAN SATELLITES, CHINA AND I
THINK WHAT IS MOST DISTURBING IS
IF YOU LOOK AT THESE TEXT
MESSAGES IS WHAT KAITLIN IS
SAYING IS THAT HE KEPT QUOTING
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES.
HE WANTED TO GET THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE INVOLVED
AND IF I'M THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, ONE OF THE REASONS I
WANT TO LOOK AT THE CONTENTS OF
HIS PHONE IS WHO IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OR
FORMERLY SAID OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WAS HE
COMMUNICATING WITH TO GET THIS
COMPLETELY FRAUDULENT
INFORMATION?
>> AND ONE OF THE WAYS THAT A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS IS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
LAST ELECTION DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN WAS THE ELECTORAL COUNT
ACT, WHICH WOULD BRING CLARITY
TO THE PART OF THE CONSTITUTION
THAT PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO
EXPLOIT TO GET PENCE TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION AND SENATE MAJORITY
CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS TO INCLUDE
THAT IN THE BIG SPENDING BILL.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID HE'S A HELL
NO ON THAT BILL SO IT'S JUST NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> I THINK IT STILL COULD.
AND OF COURSE, THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO THIS BEFORE McCARTHY HAS A
SPEAKER FIGHT, HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY POTENTIALLY TO
BECOME HOUSE SPEAKER AND BEFORE
REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER THE
MAJORITY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT WE SAW
SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS TODAY SAY
WE NEED TO ENACT THIS G GET THIS
IN PLACE BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR, BEFORE THE 2024
PRESIDENTIAL CYCLE STARTS TO
HEAT UP.
IF THEY DO THAT, I THINK IT HAS
A CHANCE OF PASSING AND TRYING
TO GET THIS INTO THE YEAR END
SPENDING BILL WILL BE DIFFICULT.
WE'RE NOT SURE IT WILL PASS.
I THINK RIGHT NOW WE SAW MITCH
McCONNELL TODAY SAY THAT IF THEY
CANNOT GET AN OMINOUS BILL DONE
BY THE END OF THE YEAR, BY
DECEMBER 22nd, THEY'RE GOING TO
GO HOME SENATORS AND THEY'LL
HAVE TO DO A LONG-TERM SHORT OR
LONGER TERM CONTINUING
RESOLUTION, WHICH IS A SHORT
TERM FUNDING BILL AND SO IT'S
REALLY GOING TO DEPEND ON
WHETHER THEY CAN FIT THIS IN AND
GET A LONG-TERM SPENDING BILL
DONE BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
>> ON THAT POINT, MITCH
McCONNELL SAID WHAT ELAINA SAID,
McCARTHY SAID SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
HE SAID I DON'T WANT TO START
THE GOVERNMENT OUT IN A
SHUTDOWN.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE US ACCOMPLISH
THINGS ON THE COMMITMENT BUT NOW
HE HAS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW.
>> I MEAN, THESE ARE THE
TOUGH
EST SEVEN WEEKS OF KEVIN
McCARTHY'S LIFE.
HE'S ALL WRONG.
HE HAS NO CALCULUS IN A FASHION
WE HAVE NOT SEEN FOR YEARS.
THE UNFAVORABLES ARE SO HIGH.
I SEE HIM EKING THIS OUT.
I DO.
>> BECOMING THE SPEAKER?
>> TO BECOME THE SPEAKER.
DID HE DESERVE THE SPEAKER'S
GAVEL?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
MANY DON'T BELIEVE IN HIM AND
WE'RE SEEING CONSTANTLY THE
PROBLEM WITH CONGRESS AND IT'S
GOING TO MAKE ITS WAY TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC SOONER THAN
LATER.
WE SEE THE FRUSTRATION, RAGE
AGAINST THE MACHINE POLITICS BUT
WHAT THIS WILL DO, THIS DOESN'T
MAKE IT BETTER FOR REPUBLICANS
TO GO BACK TO THE BASE AND SAY
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO REWRITE THE
RULES FOR YOU BECAUSE THE RULES
ARE WRONG.
THEY'RE SHOWING THEY HAVE NO
SOLUTION AND NO WAY AND CAN'T
FIND A WAY.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I WONDER HOW YOU WOULD ANSWER
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE EARLIER
TODAY, MANU RAJU SAID HOW MATT
GAETZ, THE MAGA REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN SAID McCARTHY
DOESN'T HAVE THE VOTES TO BE
SPEAKER, AND McCARTHY SAYS I DO.
WHO DO YOU BELIEVE, ME OR MATT
GAETZ?
I THOUGHT THAT'S A TOUGH
QUESTION.
>> THAT IS A VERY TOUGH
BUT I THINK YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
HE ALSO SAID REPUBLICANS WERE
GOING TO GOVERN AND FOCUS ON
BRINGING SOLUTIONS ON INFLATION
AND CRIME AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY RAN ON.
THE FIRST THING THEY ANNOUNCE?
INVESTIGATIONS.
POSSIBLE IMPEACHMENTS AND NOW
THEY'RE OBSESSED AND FOCUSED ON
THE SPEAKERSHIP AND WHAT IS
KEVIN McCARTHY DOING?
HE'S SELLING OUT TO HIS MAGA
CONSTITUENTS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO GET TO THE NUMBER THAT HE
NEEDS TO GET FOR THIS AND WHAT
THIS SAYS TO ME, THERE'S GOING
TO BE A BIG SPLIT IF IT CAN GET
ANY BIGGER BETWEEN THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS AND THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS.
McCONNELL IS SPEAKING COMMON
SENSE.
HE WANTS TO GET THIS DONE, I
BELIEVE.
HE WANTS TO GET THIS DONE
BECAUSE HE KNOWS HOW THIS IS
GOING TO LOOK IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY YET AGAIN, IF THEY DON'T
GET THIS DONE AND THERE'S A
POSSIBLE SHUTDOWN AND ALL OF THE
CHAOTIC REST OF IT, THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
ELECTION, RIGHT?
THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS WERE
FOCUSED ON ELECTION DENIERS AND
A LOT OF THEM STILL WON.
THERE IS STILL 147 REPUBLICANS
THAT DIDN'T CERTIFY THE ELECTION
IN CONGRESS BUT THE SENATORS,
THEY SAW WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY GAVE VOICE TO THOSE
NON-COMMON SENSE REPUBLICANS TO
THE ELECTION DENIERS.
THEY LOST THE SENATE AND SO I
THINK THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO
BE LOOKED AT IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AS TO WHO IS GOING TO WIN
AND THERE IS GOING TO BE A BIG
BATTLE STILL, THEY HAVE NOT
LEARNED THEIR LESSON IN TERMS OF
THE ELECTION.
AT LEAST THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS --
>> THAT BATTLE IS STILL AHEAD.
I BELIEVE THE WORST IS YET TO
COME FOR THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IN THE HOUSE.
>> THEY ONLY HAVE, WHAT, FOUR OR
FIVE VOTES THAT McCARTHY CAN
ONLY LOSE FOUR VOTES IN IT,
RIGHT?
>> IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER TO
HAVE NOT WON THE HOUSE.
THIS SLIM OF A MARGIN?
MY GOSH.
HOW WILL HE CORRAL THIS --
>> HOW IS HE GOING TO STAY
SPEAKER?
>> IS IT POSSIBLE HE DOESN'T GET
THE SPEAKERSHIP?
THAT THERE IS --
>> HONESTLY --
>> THERE IS NOT --
>> THERE IS TALK --
>> THERE IS NOT A STRONG
ALTERNATE CANDIDATE.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
THERE ISN'T A STRONG ALTERNATE
CANDIDATE.
TO EXPLAIN TO THE VIEWERS,
ASSUMING THEY DON'T GET THIS
OMINOUS SPENDING BILL THROUGH,
THEN IT GOES TO THE NEXT
CONGRESS WHEN KEVIN McCARTHY IS
IN CHARGE THEORETICALLY, SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE LET'S ASSUME THAT
HAPPENS.
THE FEAR, I THINK, THAT A LOT OF
MODERATE REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE IS KEVIN McCARTHY
CAN ONLY LOSE FOUR VOTES.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING TO WANT
TO OWN ANY OF THESE FIGHTS.
AND YOU'LL HAVE THE MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENES OF THE WORLD
MAKING BIG DEMANDS AND HAVING
THE POWER TO DO SO.
>> HAVING SUCH A NARROW MAJORITY
IS A NIGHTMARE FOR McCARTHY AND
WHOEVER CONTROLS THE SPEAKER
SHIP.
TO WHAT WE WERE DISCUSSING ABOUT
ONE, WITH THE SPENDING PACKAGE,
HE SAYING WAIT UNTIL THE
MAJORITY, REPUBLICANS HAVE THE
MAJORITY, HE DOESN'T WANT THAT.
HE DOESN'T WANT THIS FIGHT TO
PLAY OUT AT THE SAME TIME THAT
HE'S TRYING TO WIN THIS
LEADERSHIP RACE AND ALSO, I DO
THINK, I MEAN, I KNOW THERE IS
TALK ABOUT WHAT KIND OF DEMANDS
CAN KEVIN McCARTHY MAKE OR KVON
EXCUSE ME TO FAR RIGHT FIGURES
LIKE SCOTT PERRY AND MATT GAETZ?
ONE THING IS IF HE DOES MAKE THE
DEMANDS, THE BIG ONE IS ON
MOTION TO VACATE THE CHAIR, A
MESSY, MESSY.
>> TO EXPLAIN THAT, DOESN'T THAT
MEAN --
>> THEY CAN MAKE A MOTION TO VAE
-- VACATE THE CHAIR.
IF HE DOES CAVE ON THIS AND IT'S
UNCLEAR RIGHT NOW, I'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT WITH HIS TEAM AND
OTHERS, HE KNOWS THAT THIS COULD
REALLY JEOPARDIZE HIS POSITION
IF HE DOESN'T CAVE BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE HOW DANGEROUS IT WOULD
BE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WOULD --
SOME OF THESE MEMBERS WOULD
STILL VOTE FOR HIM AFTER THIS.
IT'S VERY PERSONAL.
>> CAN I JUST